if you had to battle horrifying Robot
Monsters what would you do you'll lose
everyone you love and your mind in order
to save the people you love I'm going to
break down the mistakes made what you
should do and how to beat the Cyber
punks in cyber Punk Edge Runners pulling
out of time and energy from your busy
schedule to fix your health problems has
always been a big headache for everyone
until now keeps is an online
subscription service that makes it easy
and more affordable for men to treat
their male pattern boldness right from
the comfort of their homes so Kickback
on your couch while you get expert hair
loss care from licensed medical
providers no trips to the doctor or the
pharmacy needed a good thing too since
keeps offers personalized affordable
treatment plans for half the price of
traditional Pharmacy prices all right to
your door in a discreet non-bed package
and with your choice of both FDA
approved hair loss treatment options
plus a twoin one gel that combines both
treatments for the hassle-free weeb out
there and you can message your medical
provider or keep's care team 24/7 and
it's including uded in all of their
subscription plans so start your
hassle-free journey to a better more
confident life with affordable cutting
Ed signs back solutions to help you
prevent and stimulate more hair growth
all day long even at the office and yes
that's a sign back to natural styling
Pomade so there's no excuse to not look
good until you look your best in no time
at all hair loss stops at keeps for a
special offer to get started go to
keeps.com how to beat anime or click the
link in the description thanks to keeps
for sponsoring the video now back to the
show this kid is going to watch all of
his teammates die David here is your
regular bottom feeder living with his
mom paycheck to paycheck in a world full
of cyber upgrade if you can pay for it
you can upgrade it but David and his mom
can't pay for he heads over to his
Rich School wondering how his mom
affords it not realizing he's being
watched unable to pay for a new class
software he downloads a fake software
but accidentally destroys the entire
School causing him to get expelled and
his mom is pissed after his heartbroken
mom complains him how many jobs she's
doing it just wants him to graduate and
get a better life but David thinks ah he
should just get a job instead and that's
when they get brutally shot up in the
middle of a gang driveby explosions
death blood it is awesome they crash the
car waking up David sees a Medics rush
to the seat but they tell him and his
mom that they're too poor to afford
premium healthc care and they leave them
for the meat wagon barely surviving his
mom eventually reaches surgery but the
doc tells David she's not in good shape
since they can't afford the best
treatment but it doesn't matter because
he has one day to pay up or the hospital
will let her die heading home oh it just
keeps on coming rent is past due
breaking in he tries to calm down and
figure out how to make some quick cash
he tries selling some things and comes
across the one thing that will cause his
downfall a lightweight cyber upgrade
that amplifies the user speed but he
doesn't know why his mom has it and why
it's military made he Rings up a Shady
Pond dealer to try and sell it but gets
low balled so he keeps it and looks for
something else to sell about to make his
biggest mistake of his life heading to
school the next next day David gets
stopped by some rich bullies telling him
he's poor and doesn't have any upgrades
and he doesn't belong here and thinks
his mom does naughty things on the side
to pay for a school pissed off David
gets into a fight with the bully but
this guy has MMA fighting upgrades and
easily kicks the out of him nose
bleeding he then gets a call from the
dog telling him he's the worst son in
the world because his mom has died and
he couldn't pay to help her now he's
alone poor and no home David cremates
his mom cuz what else can he do and he
sneaks back into his fore clo department
and then he gets a call from the school
bully telling him he's glad his mom died
his mind breaks and he eyes up the one
thing he thinks that will solve all his
problems going to a black market surgeon
he makes the biggest mistake of his life
and he upgrades his body for the first
time the doc warns him that he couldn't
sell this Tech because no one is crazy
enough to use it it will rot his mind
and Fry his brain because of its power
but he doesn't listen after he goes back
to class and starts a fight with the
school bully but this time he easily
beats him him using his hyper Advanced
military upgrade freaked out the bully
tells him his father is one of the
executives of the school and oh he's
screwed David rushes back home and
passes out and this stunt will cost him
being monitored by the bully's Dad
takahara here he spots David on the
camera shocked he wonders how a little
kid like David can handle using this
machine so many times unlike others
before him and he plans to capture him
to experiment on his body okay well
David acted like a stud he also acted
like a dumbass I would have beaten this
kid's ass by relying on Shady Black
Market dealers and looking out for
something that could have predicted this
Bully's Behavior by 93% let me explain
he knows this Tech was Black Market
Military it's safe to assume that
whoever used this Tech would have been
targeted anyways I mean he's just asking
for more problems to come his way cuz
last thing we needed was making more
problems to find us the moment we put
this thing on and this would have let us
know how carefully we could have been
using it or should have been using it
because definitely stolen military Tech
and public is definitely going to draw
some eyes if I was him before doing
anything I would have looked into how
valuable this Tech was asking around
different black market dealers about it
pretending that I the stupid kid want to
buy it without actually revealing that
we already have it duh by doing it this
way trying to make a sale most dealers
would have probably hyped this product
up and overvalued it hoping we would pay
them to try and get it for us by knowing
a ton of info on what we were about to
put on would have helped us to see if
using this thing was actually worth it
long term and then knowing the risks I
still would have kicked this bully's ass
cuz no one disrespects my mom like
seriously what the freak is that but
instead of going after him at school
where there are cameras I would have
waited like a shark in the water
watching this bully and picking up the
one thing that makes everyone
predictable their routine on average
normal human behavior is 93% predictable
When taking into account their routines
almost everyone follows a similar
pattern regardless of time and distance
and they have a strong tendency to
return to locations they visited before
by simply following the bully for a few
days we could have figured out pretty
much everything we needed to know about
him and could have figured out where to
kick his ass and where there were less
cameras around he's a punk that likes to
play dirty which means he probably acts
dirty and likes to go to underground
spots away from Daddy's eye for fun time
that may or may not have cameras or
there's good people who wouldn't care if
someone around them got beat up hell
they probably join in and this is where
we could have safely and responsibly
kicked his Rich ass away from the
cameras and away from the school the
next day David Takes the Train and
figures out his next plan but spot the
same girl he saw the other day
pickpocketing trying to stop her she
spots his Tech but doesn't tell him and
she says she's only stealing from people
that work for one of the biggest
companies in the world the same one good
old David's bully dad works for arasaka
Corporation David tells her she's crazy
cuz these guys run everything in the
world and she offers to partner up with
him saying her name is Lucy but he's
desperate for quick catch and David
agrees using his cyberware more times in
one day than anyone before him that was
his biggest mistake after they wrap up
he gets a nose bed and suddenly passes
out getting picked up by an ambulance
Lucy finds out from David that he hasn't
been taking any medicine to up his body
except his cyberware rookie mistake and
she calls him nuts and suddenly the
Medics stick them up and tell her that
David cyberware is worth a lot of money
about to steal it Lucy thinks fast and
escapes with David like a maniac he
thinks she's crazy and tells her to take
him to his local surgeon arriving the
surgeon finds out that David used his
Tech eight times in one day shocked he
tells him most adults wouldn't be able
to handle using this more than a few
times and tells him he should use his
Tech twice a day Max and he warns David
unlike most implants using this Tech
long enough will cause his brain to fry
and he will go crazy but David doesn't
listen and after Lucy pays for some
anti- crazy medicine for David and tells
him he owes her and they'll continue to
work together until he pays her back but
not to use his Tech unless he has to
walking her back home she invites David
in and they chill out and chat and she
shows him her VR game if you know what I
mean until suddenly this guy shows up
telling David that the implant is his
and knocks him out waking up moments
later he meets this gang they ask him
why he's wearing their Tech finding out
that their Tech supplier was David's mom
and that's how she afforded to send him
a fancy School revealing his mother is
now dead they get sad surprisingly but
warn him to hand over his Tech or else
desperate for an ounce of power in his
life David offers a compromise if he can
keep this Tech he will work for them
until he pays them back showing off that
he used his Tech more times than any
other person before him making the gang
think his body might be really good at
handling cyberware feeling bad for him
they agree to take him out on a test job
while he secretly gets sad that Lucy
played him the next day his old school
asks him to come back free of charge but
he ignores them and heads to meet Lucy's
gang instead kiwi Doro pylar Becca and
Maine who will all die in horrifying
ways to help David achieve his dream
Maine here shows him the mission steal
data from this bodyguard who works for
the arasaka corporation while he go
visits his usual bar heading there they
follow the bodyguards routine and wait
for him to go inside while David and
Lucy work un hacking the car's GPS but
suddenly The Bodyguard gets called into
work by his boss and starts heading back
out to his car gang member Becca here
gets the signal and tries to buy time
but it's too late coming out e spots
David and Lucy trying to get in main
tells David change of plans he needs to
drive shocking David he starts up his
first car ride and shows the gang that
he has what it takes driving away they
realize they can't get rid of the GPS
data and must head to their mechanic
shop first just as they get caught by
gang members because The Bodyguard is
put a hit on his car making David
realize how powerful the arasaka company
really is running into traffic David
uses his powers to drive like a madman
and gets one gang member off of their
tail reaching the hidden location
another one shows up about to kill David
but Lucy saves him and he repays the
favor completing his first mission later
M welcomes him to the crew and takes
care of his anti crazy medicine needs
for a whole month and even pays him
parting the night away this one guy
arrives to meet Maine and the man who
will betray them Faraday working for the
Osaka's biggest company milch he scolds
Maine for attracting too much attention
for this job and tells them that even
though they got the data this stunt now
put Tanaka back on high alert making
their data on him pointless Maine tries
to ask more questions about the job
telling Faraday because he keeps them in
the dark it makes it very hard to do
their job properly but this guy calls
them lap dogs and warns them to wait
until arasaka lowers his guard again
because they will get caught and the
next job will pay them big later David
learns about the gang life while they
wait for Faraday to call them and he
gets a call from his old school they
offer him to come back for free again
but he tells them no and becomes an
official gang banger installing new tech
and becoming a full-on cyber junkie
training with Lucy and becoming stronger
he starting to love the power not
realizing this will kill him Maine tells
him that he can't rely on just cyberware
and needs to train the body until his
body can handle stronger Tech to
training Arc he becomes a badass mofo
moving on his gang is out and about when
they spot something strange a half man
half robot is talking to himself one of
David's gang members goes up to him to
check on him but suddenly gets his face
blown off shocking the gang and David
gets a taste of someone he knows Dying
For the First Time Becka here Springs
into action going nuts oh we love her M
announces what everyone is thinking this
man has been upgraded for too long and
has now gone full cyber psycho just like
David will soon become and that makes
one down six more to go thinking quick
David spots Lucy about to die forcing
him to use his cyberware saving her and
making his first kill after he gets
instructed to take Lucy home and there
they talk and she reveals to him that he
was the first person she took in her VR
game showing him her dream to visit the
moon she thinks unlike others he's a
good guy and unlike her he has places to
go and doesn't want him to end up like
so many other gang bangers but he
reveals that he wants to help her reach
dreams and they kiss the next day Maine
sees David smiling and not being a buzz
kill and now he knows he got late and
gives him a hard time they then find out
a new lead to finally find Tanaka
because Faraday has received news
they're targeting something big for
their company to find Tanaka they should
start with this famous guy Jimmy
kurasaki an artist he makes these super
realistic VR movies of people's deaths
that clients pay big money to watch
tracking him down to this garage David
pretends to be a fan distracting him and
Maine comes up from behind but suddenly
gets hit with his EMP device knocking
them all out and Jimmy escapes but takes
David with him he wakes up a little
later now subdued by dead bodies no idea
what just happened and the cops rush in
and call him a cyber psycho freaking him
out he brutally Slaughters them getting
shot witnessing his own death and
suddenly he wakes up and realizes he's
trapped in one of Jimmy's VR machines
Jimmy tells him that what he just saw
was a recreation of James norse's recent
death the previous owner of the
cyberware who went crazy after wearing
it he was a special soldier with the
mind of a warrior warning him if David
keeps using this Tech he was soon lose
his mind just like him and Jimmy will
plays the messed up a video hoping David
will go crazy soon but that's when
Lucy's gang goes in blasting breaking
David out and they see now they're
surrounded by armed drones Lucy tries to
hack them but David uses his cyberware
to stop them using up more precious
energy he trips and Lucy saves him and
they manage to capture Jimmy with the
setup in place they lure his best client
Tanaka to him with a new product to sell
him a few hours later Tanaka enters in
excited but that's when the gang blocks
up all the signals from the room so he
can't call for backup they try to
interrogate at him but he whips out some
special moves and knocks main down and
he recognizes David from school Jimmy
gets killed in the crossfire but they
realize Jimmy has crazy good medical
insurance installed inside of him which
means doctors plus cops will show up to
rescue him in a few minutes forcing
David's team to kidnap Tanaka and run
before they get caught arriving at their
safe house main starts to realize that
his robot parts are starting to mess
with his mind the others think he should
take off some cyberware for a while to
let his body rest but he likes power too
much the idiot and meanwhile kiwi here
tries to hack Tanaka software to extract
dad about his company for Faraday but
suddenly Maine loses his and knocks
out kiwi forcing Lucy to take her place
she thinks she's not as good as kiwi but
goes in anyways paranoid about Maine
they tell him to buzz off in case he
loses his again and they try to
hack his dad up before morning but
that's when Tanaka wakes up trapping
Lucy inside of his mind and he tells
David he knows who he is and begs to
make a deal with him he can go back to
his old life where it's safe and it'll
be a good corporate little service cuz
Lucy's gang is using him and he's not
safe meanwhile inside Tanaka's mind Lucy
finds out the aisaka corporation has now
targeted David to use him for their
robot experiment since his body can
handle it the big news for arasaka
Corporation is David scared for him and
wanting to destroy all traces of him in
Osaka's system she fries Tanaka's
cyberware hoping Faraday will also never
find out and this causes Tanaka to start
dying the rest of the gang comes back in
shocked to see him awake and about to
die they order David to pull Lucy out
saving both her and the data they
quickly prepare for what's coming next
and again because good old Tanaka has
awesome medical insurance they know
they'll be here in a few minutes and
made orders David to escape with Lucy
while him and some others stay behind to
slow the police down waking up from the
deep deep dive Lucy lies and says
there's no data of any kind inside of
him not telling anyone what she really
saw big mistake David and Lucy head into
the getaway car but notices David
doesn't start the engine he thinks they
should wait for the others and thinks
Lucy did see something inside of Tanaka
but she doesn't tell him the truth for
some reason so he decides to go save
Maine back inside Maine and his team
blast incoming cops left and right but
that's when he starts losing it and ends
up accidentally killing his own teammate
and finally turns into a fullon cyber
psycho killing Tanaka and the rest of
all of the cops here forcing everyone to
evacuate from this monster David finally
shows up and tries to help him out but
he tells him that it's time for him to
face his demons sending off an explosion
just as David uses his device to barely
escape and returns and escapes with Lucy
along with Main's powerful Tech arms and
now that's two down and five more to go
after Lucy ends up quitting the gang
life to secretly stop anyone who tries
to Target David while David Goes deeper
down the gang life Rabbit Hole a few
months later David is now the new group
leader full of new tech upgrades and he
loves the Power gang banging left and
right killing baddies and taking names
doing side missions for extra cash he
goes to meet up with his dog for another
cyber Tech upgrade but the dog tells him
he should chill out because he's now got
too much Tech in his body and he will go
crazy soon if he keeps this up but he
doesn't listen and puts more Tech on him
preparing to meet his gang's old Shady
partner faray he tells David that since
he's become the new leader of the group
he wants to continue working with him
but wants to test his team with a job
going against milch's biggest rival
arasaka he reveals that he heard that
Lucy hacked Tanaka's cyber security
despite her not finding information he
still wants her on this new job cuz she
got skills but David tells him she's
quit the gang life so heading home to
meet his Bay he tries to convince her to
join the gang again but she says she
needs more time not telling him that
she's secretly going after all of the
arasaka members trying to come for David
but David asks her about her backstory
that we don't care about but all she
focuses on is his hand twitching
thinking he's starting to go cyber
psycho but he tells her that he's fine
totally fine the next night David and
his gang take on be job and sneak into
this aisaka facility to steal some data
but David accidentally ends up killing
this innocent employee reminding him of
his mother he runs out and tries to
ignore what he's becoming a coldblooded
killer not realizing that arisaka has
caught on to Lucy and pled something
evil to stop her they send thugs to hit
up Faraday and nearly get him killed
freaking out he complains to his milit
bosses that he needs more protection but
they underappreciate him and tell him he
isn't getting until he finishes the
job since he messed up on the initial
Tanaka job with no help and now scared
for his own life he ends up double
crossing his own company milch and goes
to work for their rival arisaka but they
tell him they want the girl that's been
killing all of their employees for the
last few months Lucy offering him a cool
million for her head and he plans to set
up David's gang up the next day David's
crew does more gang banging jobs but
Becca starts to notice him acting
different she checks in on him telling
him that maybe he should take a break
from his robot implants but he tells her
he's a pimp a little later David relives
the innocent woman he murdered and
passes out Lucy rescues him and takes
him to the dock and he reveals that
David is now officially starting to lose
control his brain can't handle being
part of too much robot Tech much longer
but he tells the surgeon to shut his big
fat mouth and give him more medicine to
stop his crazy instead grabbing the dock
and slamming him into the wall fed up he
gives David nine times the normal dose
and tells him that he'll see him on the
news very soon when he's dead okay what
happened here to David is super obvious
if we think about how freaking merging
technology with our skin can be let me
explain because this problem is already
happening in our world today right now
with subdermal microchips Tech is
implanted basically right on the outer
layer of your skin sort of tell help you
pay do computer stuff with just your
hand but this little microchip can cause
you with so many problems which science
is still dealing with adverse tissue
reaction implanted transponder migration
electromagnetic interference cancer
risks although these cases are rare and
this only gets worth with more advancing
Tech being worked on today like
something known as a brain computer
interface the BCI which is a device that
basically communicates directly to the
brain through an external device that
allows people to use their mind instead
of an Alexa assistant however a much
more accurate way of using Tech to let
you communicate is through a risky
process know know as a neural BCI
implant where they literally cut open
your head and attach Tech right onto
your brain and this is where we run into
problems like David is facing right now
part of brain implants relies on stuff
like electrodes which basically acts as
a phone line from the implant to the
brain so they can talk to each other but
stuff like this being attached to the
brain is dangerous because it can create
scar tissues around the areas that
regulate short-term memory and emotion
and this can cause all sorts of crazy
to happen and on top of that using
implants for too long can cause
inflammation infection or the implant
could malfunction all of this explains
why why David's going crazy with too
much Tech not just in his brain but all
over his body as good old Jay-Z once
said sort of more robot Parts more
potential problem add to this he
literally just killed someone and is
suffering from something called PTSD
David should have known he of all people
would have been more sensitive to
developing Trauma from the simple fact
that he came from a lowincome background
as people raised in poverty have a
higher risk factor being more
psychologically vulnerable to developing
trauma symptoms later in life because he
grew up feeling chronically stressed out
his whole life worrying about money
worrying about rent about how his family
would survive every single day making
his body super sensitive to all of this
so combining Tech with an already weak
psychological profile means that he was
a taking time bomb from the start no
matter how tough or special he thought
he was and for a gang that specializes
in Tech upgrades and murder they should
have better prepared for dealing with
this type of stuff since it's no doubt
that it would have happen in almost
every instance since most members come
from lowincome backgrounds and have tons
of problems which makes them each a
ticking Time Bomb too after Lucy tries
to make him slow down but he tells her
that he can't stop until he reaches his
mom's dream and Main's dream succeeding
in life and helping the gang get out
ahead he finally confesses to her that
he killed an innocent woman the other
day whoops and is on the verge of losing
it asking her to come back into the gang
but she tells him that she can't just do
that yet cuz she has stuff she needs to
do not telling David again that she's
secretly stopping all arisaka agents
trying to get to him for some reason
making him sad for no reason and he
thinks she wants to secretly break up
with him she freaks out and says she
will tell him the truth soon leaving to
go take care of some more secret
business following a lead on another
arasaka employee she enters the building
and tries to take this guy out but runs
right into fa trap realizing kiwi has
been working for Faraday this whole time
betraying the gang so she can save her
own ass from being a Target the next day
David prepares for the big Faraday job
knowing the risks he tells Rebecca to
keep pumping him full of anti- crazy
meds so he can keep fighting wa worried
for him she agrees like a good old
friend and they head off for their final
job they just have to steal this cargo
truck but they don't know where Lucy is
kiwi returns but keeps her mouth shut
and leads them right into the Trap
intercepting the trucks they start
blasting but soon get overwhelmed
forcing David to use his device more and
more his nose is now bleeding and they
reach the the target truck and they
realize it's on autopilot and something
isn't right he uses his cyberware again
to stop the truck so they can look
inside and he calls for Lucy but still
gets no response and thinks it's a trap
suddenly hundreds of milit arrive and
start shooting confusing the group kiwi
tells them to take cover in the truck
and inside they spot what Faraday was
after this cyber skeleton this is just
like David's but way more advanced they
think arisaka is trying to overtake
militech in the robot business just then
David Gets a call from Lucy telling him
that arasaka is after her and he needs
to get into the suit to come help her
which is weird because she literally
just told him to chill out on the
upgrades earlier and she ends the call
before he can ask any questions Rebecca
thinks something is going on but kiwi
rushes David to hurry up and get in the
suit with no choice he straps into the
suit and starts becoming a full-on
monster while kiwi secretly knocks out
one of his gang members and escapes and
everything's going exactly as faray
plans him and the arasaka company watch
what David will do to their competitor
jeez the gang getting setup just now is
only the result of their stupidity
because they didn't take this job
seriously enough you think so oh no no
they didn't since the beginning they've
only been taking small to medium job
from hacking dad as from Cars dealing
with shootouts and even corporate
Espionage however in those jobs there
were common elements present throughout
one while the reasoning was unclear why
they were doing certain things most of
the obstacles that they would face was
known in advance two they had a clear
and easy Escape Route committing jobs in
the state at all times and three they
were extremely familiar with all the
terrain in all missions this Mission
from the beginning they didn't know what
was inside these trucks or why they were
after it but they also didn't bother to
prepare for where the mission would take
place even though the mission was in an
area they weren't used to and this job
was clearly going to be the risky one
yet if they actually prepared properly
it would have been obvious from them
bringing more members onto This Job
showing up with more advanced cyberware
or getaway vehicles or a clear Escape
option in case went South and for
the person they carried out this mission
for was someone who was clearly a SLE
Ball even if we didn't know what was
going to happen I would have tried to
figure out who Faraday really was by
getting to know the only language people
like him know money while knowing the
why behind what we're doing is important
figuring out the man behind it all could
have helped us figured out his reasoning
for taking this job in the first place
and this could have given him some
insight on how life likely he was to
screw us over or not because the main
cause of job dissatisfaction over 70% of
the time is this stuff but it really
comes down to one factor managers and
one of the most common complaints being
money related in order to figure out how
committed Faraday was to his cause I
would have tried to learn all about his
work life balance what was he getting
paid for was it enough and whether or
not he was arisaka company's little
and this probably would have given
us an idea How likely F would have
screwed us over which also could have
helped us prepare for our own defenses
in case he ever did you see what I'm
saying meanwhile the real Lucy freeze
herself from Faraday and escapes quickly
calling up David telling him it's a trap
that Faraday has switched sides and they
want to see how his body reacts to this
dangerous Tech but she gets knocked out
again and farad Reveals His ugly head
telling him that if he wants to save
anybody he should put on the suit and
show everyone what he's made up because
he won't get out alive otherwise Rebecca
then stabs him with more anti- crazy
meds and the mustache gang member comes
back and tells them that kiwi betrayed
them with no choice David suits up with
his new suit anti-gravity boosted
weapons blood all the good you know
it's crazy he mows down everyone like
Magneto on on crack showing crazy
tolerance to this cyber suit clearing up
all the enemies with these him and his
gang go to save Lucy tracking Lucy they
make a run for the arasaka headquarters
while milit and arasaka go after him not
realizing arasaka is calling on their
biggest weapon ever Adam Smasher Rebecca
then gives David their trap card
military grade anti- crazy meds for
special cyberware operators Rebecca
tells him by the time he hits this last
dose there's no coming back injecting
himself with new energy he starts
blasting again and he starts drifting
Between Worlds she gets sad seeing her
friend slow die and the guy carries on
to head towards the arasaka headquarters
meanwhile kiwi gets double crossed by
Faraday and she regrets turning so evil
good and she tells David's crew last
minute where Lucy really is before dying
whatever she betrayed them that's three
down and four more to go back on David
he shoots up his final medicine and he
jumps off near the base and rushes to
save Lucy badly injuring Faraday in the
process spotting the man that will kill
him Adam Smasher he tries to escape
David sees this but that's when Adam
badly injures him with a new and better
suit causing him to go full psycho
killing everyone and escaping with Lucy
while getting shot by Adam nearby
Landing he meets up with the rest of the
gang while shooting down some bad guys
and he messes around and Rebecca
suddenly gets crushed by Adam and the
whole Squad gets injured now that's four
down and three more to go shocked David
is forced to use his device but quickly
realizes Adam has one too and calls
David old Tech out of anti- craz meds
and now on the verge of death Lucy tries
to stop Adam and hack into his brain but
he's too strong and sens are flying back
this mustache guy starts driving her
away and reveals that this was David's
plan all along to give up his life for
her okay this could have been all
avoided if David stopped acting like a
little inconsiderate brat let me explain
David is screwed because he has been
following other people's dreams that his
own his whole time if I was him at this
point trying to fight Adam Smasher was
completely pointless even if we were
trying to save Lucy we exhausted okay
and on the edge of cyber psychosis and
we're fighting Adam with tech that he
already has and is more familiar with
we're fighting with a bigger fish here
it's clear that our suit was not made
for close of battles all anyone had to
do was to destroy this thing up close
and we'd be toast aside from sacrificing
ourselves for no reason when we landed
we could have either left on top of the
car with the new crew since there was at
least a minute or two before Adam landed
and right before the group was making
jokes duh this is why Rebecca got killed
or we could have simply left the group
the moment we dropped Lucy off and
gained some distance between us and Adam
since it was clear he was after mainly
us the others were just in the way since
this was so obvious from beforehand
since David seemed to really only care
about Lucy being saved since he could
have saved Rebecca if he didn't
dilly-dally when he landed meanwhile
Adam tries to stop Lucy but gets
distracted by David pissing him off he
destroys David's anti-gravity thrusters
making him collapse under the weight of
his suit and David gets ripped alive
knowing that he saved Lucy and her
dreams of going to the moon it's great
he's super happy and Adam blows his head
off makes it now five down and no more
to go sometime later thanks to the money
David left she gets to the moon and
lives out her dream but starts
hallucinating that David is alive and
she quickly realizes that this is a
vision and gets sad and stares out into
the sun wondering what the point of all
of this was but what do you guys think
about the video don't forget to like
subscribe and leave a thumbs up down
below and as always don't forget to
check out our how toe playlist